are you brand-new to YouTube or you've
started a channel already but you're
just stuck well in today's video we're
going to be walking you through the
advice for new youtubers four tips for
growing your YouTube channel that
actually work but if we're just meeting
my name is Heather Torres and I'm the
CEO here I think media and the host of
the think marketing show and today I
also have with us Melissa from think
media how you doing Melissa I'm good I'm
happy to be here and talking about these
tips with you yes and I think this is
such a great topic to talk about right
now Melissa because there are so many
people that are starting YouTube it's
like YouTube is growing so big right now
because business owners are wanting to
get on YouTube we have creators who are
ready to lean in and actually go all-in
on YouTube and so are you ready to get
with the four tips Mel oh yes okay
awesome so let me bring this up here and
today we're gonna be talking about the
four tips for growing your YouTube
channel that actually work and the first
tip for growing your YouTube channel is
not working here we go is to choose your
niche to choose your niche now what does
this mean well this means that if you
are gonna get started on YouTube you
need to tell YouTube what you're about
you need to tell YouTube who you are and
how you're going to serve people so
choosing a niche is critical now this
doesn't mean that when you get started
on YouTube that you can't experiment
with different types of videos that you
can't experiment with maybe different
parts of who you are or what you want to
talk about but it is critical that when
you start on YouTube that you have some
type of North Star where are you going
who do you serve and how do you serve
them so a great way to think about this
is if you're gonna be starting if you're
gonna be stuck in an elevator with
someone and then you say oh what do you
do or what's your channel about you
would need to have a one phrase line
what what do you do so here at think
media we help people with the best tips
and tools for growing their online
business it's critical to us to help
people learn how to do YouTube right
that's our one liner thing
Media that's what we do here at think
marketing and so it's so important that
when you are starting on YouTube that
you start with a niche that you know who
you are talking to now if you are just
getting started on the platform and
you're just really wanting to understand
how to do video creation in general I
really recommend that you go through
what's called the experimental phase
which means maybe one day you talk about
your plans and maybe the next day you're
talking about raising your kids and then
the next day you're talking about how
you love to run those our group that's
an experimental phase but then we
recommend that you choose a niche
because the person that you want to talk
to needs to know that you're talking to
them they need to know that you're for
them and they needs to know that you are
the one that has the advice that they
can trust and so it's really really
critical to pick a niche all right
number two number two is the asq formula
the asq formula well I'm gonna share
what that is but if you're just joining
us right now let us know in the chat
where you're watching from this is a
live broadcast and if you're on the
replay
let us know in the comments what a
hashtag replay and where you're watching
from we want to know who your who's here
and who's watching I'm the think
marketing show but the asq formula is
answer specific questions well answer
specific questions it's critical when
you're creating videos to be the person
that is answering specific questions and
the way we like to think about this is
think about the really simple things
think about the exact question so one of
our VRA students one of our video
ranking Academy students has a cooking
channel and he made an entire video all
about how to clean a cast iron what is
it called Mel a cast iron pot a cast
iron what's a good pan thank you see you
could tell I don't cook hash tag I don't
cook he made a whole video on cleaning a
cast iron pan this video this video guys
literally has two million views two
million views on this video by Kowboy
Kent and it is amazing to see what he's
been able to do let me see if I can
actually pull no can't pull that one in
okay so
and we want you to answer specific
questions so when you're thinking about
the video ideas that you're doing really
think about what is the exact question
so for me on my home-school channel I
have a separate homeschooling channel I
could answer the specific question
homeschooling versus public schooling
question mark or I can answer the
specific question best homeschooling
books for new moms that's a specific
thing that I am answering and that my
video would be only about that thing and
where we see people new youtubers going
wrong and wasting their time is that
they're making these videos they're
answering way too many questions or
aren't answering any specific questions
at all mell on your channel what are
some specific questions that you've
answered yeah so I try to just get down
to the most basic questions that I can
think of so things like I like to talk
about sustainable and ethical products
so I talk about like what is an ethical
product or what is the best ethical you
know basic shirt and it's just those
baseline questions that I know everybody
interest in this topic is going to be
answering mm-hmm and another one from
vidi Rankin Academy we had McCann dogs
they did will link all these down below
if you want to check them out in the
YouTube description they did one about
how to stop a puppy from biting how to
stop a puppy from biting so that's very
specific that's like one it's a dog
channel - it's about puppies and three
it's a behavior so they've gone really
niche and even how they're answering
that question that video almost has a
million views answer specific questions
let me know in the chat or if you're
watching on the replay what is your next
video that you're going to create that's
answering a specific question
alright the tip number three and then
we'll get right into Q&A if you have
questions for Melissa and I today go
ahead and ask those inside of the chat
if you're watching live or we're going
to come back to this video right now
we're going to come back to this video
and if you have a question that you want
to get answered we'll be inside of the
comment section to make sure we're
answering those questions but number
three number three is be consistent
let's say it all together
everyone at one time be
be consistent this is the hardest part
of being a video creator because you
know it gets views on YouTube videos on
YouTube so you actually have to be
posting content on the platform in order
to even have the likelihood of getting
views on your video so being consistent
is so important and here's why when
you're starting something when you show
up let's say let's say someone says hey
let's get together on Tuesday and really
yes
I'm clearing my schedule I'm gonna be
there at Tuesday Tuesday what time
Tuesday at 4:00
okay Tuesday at 4:00 great and then
their girlfriend calls you and she goes
oh sorry I can't today I would just how
to do my hair that's always the excuse
right I had it in my hair um you'd be a
little bummed and you'd start to lose
trust what if that friend did that to
you three times or four times or
basically told you they were gonna do
something and then never did it again
you lose trust and the same thing
happens on YouTube so when you are
creating videos we want you to know that
one of the best ways to grow on YouTube
is to just show up be the person that
shows up for your people be the person
that stays consistent be either person
that that sticks with it now I
understand
seasons of life can happen things like
what's happening right now in our world
can happen but through it all be
consistent because it's not only gonna
build your muscle of trustworthiness to
yourself but it's also going to be
building the know like and trust with
your audience and that is a huge deal if
you want to be the person that people
are following right if you want to be
the influencer or the leader of the
movement that you're doing whatever that
is it could be anything that you're
doing you can be dog training it could
be cooking it can be exercise it could
be homeschooling it could be marketing
it could be anything but here's the
thing you've got to show up for your
people why should they show up for you
if you're not willing to show up for
them it is critical that you make it a
consistent part of your week to get a
video out now we have lots of training
materials will leak those down in the
description box below if you want to go
deeper on even understanding how to do
YouTube we have a free master class that
you can take so make sure to check out
down in the description box below
because that will help you figure out
well okay Heather I want any consistent
how do I be consistent and we walk you
through that master class alright Mel
are you ready for tip number four let's
do it all right let's do it do we have
some questions coming in yes not very
pumped about the tip so far okay okay
great all right
so number four number four you want to
be folder viewer you want to be for the
viewer this is a critical piece that new
youtubers miss when we're creating
content we're not actually creating
content for ourselves
I'm actually not creating this video for
myself I'm creating it for you it's you
and me right here you're watching your
phone you're on your desktop it's you
and me ml we're all here but this video
is created for you it's created for your
benefit and the reason we're even
creating this video with this title and
these four tips is because you asked for
it the community asked us for it the
viewer asked us for it
so tip number four if you're just
starting out this is what actually works
being for your viewer meaning don't
create content that you want to create
create content that they want to create
you know it reminds me of Mary Mary from
Mary's nest
she's one of our video raking Academy
students and Mary just did an interview
with Tony from the from the think media
team and she said that when she got
started Mary is a wonderful flat wise
woman and she creates traditional style
food so she's all about like
nutrient-dense food and she's not like a
young influencer who grew up with all
the technology she is very much her own
woman who just understands what her
craft is and what she's good at and that
is feeding people good feeding people
really good food and so Mary when she
started on YouTube she decided that she
was just going to make videos that her
audience was asking for now I get it
you're like Heather I'm just starting
how do I even know what people want to
know your people are out there they're
already online they're already inside of
groups they're already on other YouTube
channels
watching other larger YouTube channels
and they're voicing their opinion of
what they want videos about they have a
struggle they have a need and so what
Mary did was Mary was friends with a
couple other people who were doing this
the larger channels that she watched for
years before she got started and she
would be active inside of the community
inside of the comments and she was even
a part of some Facebook groups and she
was also doing some local cooking
classes some local baking classes in her
home she just decided to invite people
over and teach young moms how to make
bread how to make broth how to do very
simple things and so what Mary did was
when she started her YouTube channel she
is uh she said that she she started just
asking questions to her people like what
do you really what do you need what do
you what can i really help you like what
are the common things that not her
audience but other viewers were asking
and she found out that no need bread
meaning like I guess I don't make
friends well I do you make bread Mel do
you make bread no okay so neither Mellor
i make right so we need to watch Mary's
video because she teaches us how do we
make bread without meeting it I don't
even know how to need let me know in the
comments or in the chat do you make
bread do you even know what meeting is
I've seen it on like you know baking
challenges where they like push the
bread that says that this field as I get
everyone um but Mary made this video it
is her best performing video this video
I think now Mary every single month is
getting a million views on her channel
guys she was for the viewer she didn't
make videos that she thought she needed
because she's been doing this for 20
years 20 30 years she's been doing this
for a long time oops my slacks showing
up ha everyone that's me and mal talking
and talking that's fun that's real life
that's what happens so where was I okay
Mary she made the noni bread she was for
her viewers so here's my challenge to
you if you're just starting out on
YouTube and you only have maybe 10
subscribers or 30 subscribers or a
hundred subscribers and you're not
really getting those comments down below
to really impact
type of content you're making I want you
to go out on the internet on Facebook I
want you to go look at hashtags on
Instagram I want you to join
conversations on Twitter and I want you
to be a part of that community that you
want to help being a part of that
community is vital so another person
that we are helping is it local dentist
he wants to get started on YouTube he
hasn't yet but he's like I don't even
know what kind of videos to make and
here's what he did he went to Facebook
in his local area and he asked if he
could just go on and do live q and A's
with moms inside of a mom's group I mean
is that guy his ideal client right there
he's just asked me they're asking him
questions and he's just taking notes and
answering them in the group but now he's
gonna go back with that I think he got
he'll probably have I don't know 25 30
questions that he can make specific
videos about on his channel right what
are we gonna do niche down we're going
to be consistent we're going to be we're
going to answer specific questions and
we're going to be for our viewers if you
do these four things if you do these
four things over and over and over
you're going to see your channel grow
we're here Melissa myself Sean
Toni Noland Omar the entire think media
and think marketing teams we are here to
help you to grow faster so that you can
reach more people and make a greater
impact because we know that you are a
Purpose Driven entrepreneur you're a
Purpose Driven Creator you have a heart
for people and we know that you want to
just help them and so we're here to help
guide you on how to do that on life all
right now those are my four tips for
today what do you think in Mel well I
think those are amazing tips and one
comment that came in as you're talking
about piece number four is you know that
being we shouldn't be for the viewer we
should you know we need to do something
that we love and it has to be a passion
that comes for us and I just want to say
that those two things aren't mutually
exclusive right needing for your viewer
and being also pursuing something that
you love and are passionate about can go
hand-in-hand and actually that's going
to be the best marriage that you can
possibly have is when you come to
YouTube and you come to your business
into social platforms with something
that you are passionate
excited about and that you truly want to
help other people understand and that's
like the baseline layer that we're going
to come into this with and then from
there you are pursuing you know what do
my people want to learn about this topic
because you know I'm really passionate
about it but what do they need to learn
and what do they want to know and then
you bring those two pieces together and
that's where you're gonna have this fire
channel that is not only you know
something you're excited and passionate
about to work on every day but also
something that is serving other people
and like Heather said is truly helping
people and as purpose-driven
entrepreneurs that is like the real gold
right there so I just wanted to speak to
that point a little bit because it's
something that I've definitely thought
about myself balancing a little bit of
those two elements but I think yeah and
I think where it also comes into play to
Mel is um one of the things mary said on
the interview that we did was she said
that you know she was a part of like
homesteading which is a larger category
in her own category of traditional
cooking and she said when i started
making videos about homesteading my
audience wasn't as engaged and the
reason was because they just loved how
mary was teaching them about traditional
food so while Mary as a person loves
homesteading the content that she wanted
to deliver to her audience that was
helping her grill faster and make a
bigger impact was actually about
traditional cooking so it's really
important to just remember that like Mel
said you of course need to have passion
and fire for what you want to create
that's why you're here on the platform
you want to help people you you have a
passion a purpose a gift that you want
to help others with or you have
something that just lights your heart on
fire that you you could just talk about
for days and that married with well what
type of content that's where you think
about like meaning for the viewer is the
type of content that you're actually
doing so here I think media when we're
creating videos about cameras and about
smart phones you know we have been
creating content Shawn itself has been
creating content on this platform
basically since it started so he could
be creating content that is like I mean
when he's talking about lights they
could be talking about see this is where
this is where my tech gap comes the lose
or whatever it's called with lights like
he could be talking about some
really intense things I want to know
that this softbox makes my skin look
good when I'm on this webcam does that
make sense so when I'm thinking about
the type of content we're creating for
think media and think marketing viewers
I'm thinking okay well I've been doing
marketing now for over a decade but
someone needs to just understand the
clarity piece of a niche see the
difference I'm passionate about
marketing but I just told you you should
figure out your niche first so that's
really where we want this to go and I
guarantee if you do those four things
consistently over and over and over
you'll start to see that you are joined
in the community you're putting your
voice out you're getting your message
out but you'll start to see your channel
grow absolutely and something that Shaun
talks about quite frequently too is just
we do have to be practical at a certain
level of like why are you and why are
you on YouTube and we all have different
reasons and if your reason is purely
like I just want to create something for
myself I just want to have fun and
create whatever I want to be creating
then that is 100% okay but you have to
consider are you also on this to create
an influence or to create money and
sometimes depending on what your
priorities are and what results you're
hoping to get you're going to prioritize
different things and so if you are
wanting to grow quickly and to you know
create a business online it is sometimes
going to potentially require you making
videos that aren't as exciting for you
like you know we're just saying is like
sometimes you're gonna have to with Mary
like maybe that wasn't the thing that
she was the most excited to create but
she realized that's what her audience
needed and so thinking really thinking
through what your priorities are and
what you want to get out of this will
help make those decisions easier as you
think through every single video so I
you know getting some clarity in the
beginning is is really really helpful
oh you guys know I'm ready I'm ready for
questions I am ready for question I'm
gonna take a sip of water real quick
what are you drinking Mel you got coffee
going today I've got my same water
bottle yeah okay so Mellon Heather art
winning today we obviously wear black
shirts and white water bottles we don't
plan this this isn't like a part of the
thing we just this is just who we are
[Laughter]
we get along as okay so question from
Kevin is what if you're struggling to
find your brand identity or what if you
have many ideas that are in all
different ages mm-hmm yeah this is uh
this is creator 101 this is this is
exactly what you Kevin and 99% of
creators struggle with and and here's
the thing when you start to think about
where you want all this to go and and
you're struggling to figure out what's
my brand identity there's two things
that come into play one at some point
you just actually have to make a choice
because not choosing is delaying you
actually making impact
that's huge it's delaying you actually
reaching people and changing their lives
think about that like you not making a
decision right now is impacting the
hundreds of thousands of people that
need your content that is really really
something I want you to take to heart so
at some point you just have to choose
and here's what's really valuable
especially on youtube is when you start
to become known for one thing then you
can start to be known for more than one
thing but the first thing you need to do
is make a choice okay what am I good at
I personally I'm Kevin I'm good at
homeschooling I'm a homeschool mom I'm
great at productivity somehow I turned
my whole life around being able to be
financially free and work on YouTube and
work with my kids from home and I've
been able to do all that because I
learned how to be productive and I
learned how to I learned how to schedule
my life I learned a lot of things right
so I could teach on that I also am super
passionate about marketing I understand
modern marketing I understand how to
build funnels I also understand how to
do Facebook ads and YouTube ads and
Instagram ads so I have that skill also
but ultimately I had to decide what Who
am I right now that's what I need you to
decide who am i right now and what I
needed to do was say I am for people
understanding how to use this platform
YouTube I am for people understanding
how to do marketing so I am teaching
marketing I am teaching YouTube that's
what I'm teaching right now that's who I
am right now now yes and I still
homeschool mom absolutely
am I crazy passionate about it
absolutely but I had to just make a
choice because here's what
happens that here is what ends up
happening I'm on a on a coaching call
with you or we're talking inside the
video ranking academy coaching group
where we're inside inner circle or we're
at growth video live and you hear how
there's a home school mom and then
you're like oh my gosh I want a home
school my kids too and so then our
relationship then transferred from me
being your teacher about marketing so
now you going well I want to know how
did you get started what did you do and
you start asking me more questions and
so now I've gone from being known as
Heather from think media to Heather from
think media and she's a homeschool mom
and she lives in Las Vegas or whatever
that is right so you at some point you
just need to decide that's number one
number two is being known for one thing
first will allow you to be known for
multiple things Shawn went through the
same journey and here's the thing it's a
journey guys this is a journey this is
not something that's gonna be overnight
you're not gonna just be like poof I
know exactly who I am I know exactly
what I'm working for every person on
this popcorn right now that has clarity
lacked clarity in the past let that let
that sink in okay every person that has
clarity that you're like oh my gosh of
course Shawn does cameras guys Shawn
struggled with the same thing he wanted
to do leadership he was a speaker he was
um he was a church pastor he was in
church ministry but everyone kept saying
hey Shawn I want to buy a camera like
camera should I buy it and he was like
boom
light bulb went off I'm the camera guy
I'm the YouTube guys do this I know all
about this so I would really just say
take some time journal out what this
what this all can look like and then
build one bridge first build one bridge
first because you need to get something
going something profitable something
working before you jump to the next
thing and we see creators all the time
Mel shake your head if you can you know
this right all the time
creators will start five projects at one
time and none of them will be finished
and they're wondering why is my youtube
channel not growing and we'll look at
that we'll look at what they're doing
written we'll say well what else are you
doing well I'm also doing this and I'm
also doing this
also doing this you need to narrow it
down to one thing get one thing working
first and then you can break through
into other things yes I think that is so
good and something like you said that
pretty much every creator has to hear at
some point yeah so if you're if you're
at that stage now if you're like wow I'm
in the stage where I don't know what I'm
doing good that means you're making
progress when you get to the stage where
you say okay like Melissa Melissa does
unethically made products that's what
she's she loves that niche and she was
like this is who I am this sort of a new
Mel also loves planting she loves
redecorating she's she's got an eye for
design but she started with just
ethically made products and she was like
this is I'm gonna plant my flag this is
what I want to be known for right now
and in the future I can then talk about
home renovation and plants and healthy
eating like I can talk about those
things in the future right now mm-hmm
yes exactly and thankfully I have great
mentorship from you guys to help me do
that not an easy thing because like with
I think a lot of us we don't naturally
gravitate to one thing so strongly like
I did I am so blessed to have had that
really distinct you know vision in my
head for what I wanted but not everyone
will and you're gonna have you're gonna
be torn between two different things and
so like Heather mentioned it's a matter
of choosing you know again thinking of
your priorities which one is going to
serve your priorities the best you know
we talked about profitable niches and so
when you know if you're thinking that
that's your priority is you want to
create a real side hustle maybe that's
the kind of direction you choose and
that's more is one of the particular
ones or maybe it's because you need a
release and you need something to like
focus on on the weekends I have fun you
choose the one that's going to be the
most fun it all comes down to your
priorities again I'm just gonna keep
preaching about it yeah it's it's really
it's really important to take a step
back in you know one of the benefits
that I really recommend think marketing
community is that you know Melissa and
myself and Shawn we've intentionally put
ourselves around people that we can talk
to about this like Melissa wants to
drift off and we'll say no no Melissa
keep going keep staying on that track
because we're creators everyone that's
why we're here
that's what we want to create YouTube
videos creators create and so a lot of
times we will get pulled in different
directions but I just want to hone in on
one more thing on this because I know
this is a huge struggle especially for
new youtubers ok just take a second take
a breath one of the reasons why we don't
want to choose is because we are afraid
of failing yep
there you go let's drop the bomb now we
are afraid of failing we're afraid of
failing in front of other people we're
afraid of choosing something and it
being wrong but I just want you to know
that we are in your corner we are here
for you to help you move to the next
level in your business we're here to
help you move through all of these
stages but in the world of business
you're going to fail Shawn had four
failed YouTube channels I had two failed
businesses before I had one that worked
it's just part of the process and so
part of moving through this and being
unable to choose is because we are
actually dealing with some internal
things that we need to actually deal
with which means are you afraid of
failing who are you afraid of feeling
write it down I was afraid of failing my
parents
I didn't finish college and I decided to
be an entrepreneur that's a huge deal
and I was afraid that I was gonna choose
the wrong thing that was gonna
disappoint them and I wasn't going to
get their approval but part of all this
is actually just learning that it's okay
to fail and if you have good people
around you like we do here at the media
like you do here inside the thick
marketing community we're just gonna
pick yourself up you're gonna move on to
the next thing and that is okay it is
okay to pivot it's okay to choose it's
okay to fail we're here to help you with
that but I just want you to know like
sometimes it's not about oh I just I
have so many things I'm passionate about
yes and what is the internal struggle
are you feeling like you're an impostor
Who am I to be teaching this Who am I to
be the person that's talking about this
Who am I I didn't I'm not certified I
didn't go to school for this but at the
same time I've got the street skills
I've got the knowledge I've done the
work and if you've done that too then
step up Here I am I am knighting you
approve
to do it okay so I just wanted to also
bring that to the table because a lot of
times the conversation could be we'll
just choose and I know from struggling
with it myself I've been there I know it
I still struggle with it today that
really internally it's that I feel like
what if I fail what if people think that
I did this and and they judge me it's
okay we're here for you right now we're
here for you yes all right let's move on
to the next question that was deep and
heavy and if you're getting value out of
this right now smash the like button
smash it don't just tap it I need to yes
Heather I liked it yes okay all right
we're going to switch a little bit to
something more tactical right Joshua is
asking what are your thoughts on using
platforms like Fiverr to outsource tasks
you're not particularly fond of doing
yourself absolutely absolutely this is
this is where in our think medium
mastermind we're telling the majority of
those business owners if you had the
funds to outsource things outsource it
outsource some nail design outsource
editing outsource social media posts
like outsource what you can because your
craft is in the skill of doing what you
do right so if I'm teaching about
homeschooling I don't actually want to
learn how to edit unless I'm passionate
about it unless like editing is my thing
it is not my thing and so that is the
first thing that I would say yes if
you're the funds to outsource outsource
but also just know that you're gonna
kiss a couple of frogs first before
Prince Charming shows up so know that
you may have to go through a few editors
know that the process gets bogged down
because now you're sending someone a you
know footage and you've got to explain
what type of things you want and the
process is messy and it's like oh I can
just do this myself faster but once you
get it going once there's a system in
place once you you and your editor or
start to groove and that dance is
happening videos can start like that and
if you are interested on what are some
of the tools we use here at think media
you can go to think media tools calm and
we'll share with you we we have vid
chops which is a editing service so if
you're
I don't really care to know about how to
edit you can send them your footage
they'll edit it back to you I think it's
within like 48 hours and then also if
thumbnails is your thing and you're like
I don't want to design thumbnails you
could hire on Fiverr or we have monster
thumbnails and monster thumbnails will
design your thumbnails for you for your
YouTube videos so we've partnered with
those two brands because we want to
bring you the best resources if you want
to be creating content but you do not
want to be the person doing those behind
the scenes things great Heather we have
a lot of questions on using down yes you
should just go in on this topic I know
it's something that you're really
passionate about and it's really helpful
for people so yeah we have a question
about if you choose a niche in the
beginning but you want to branch out
into other things how do you do that
without being all over the place yeah I
I would like you to apply the 80/20 rule
8020 rule because I get it it's hard
sometimes you're like I just want to
make a fun vlog video and it doesn't
need to necessarily be like the video
that's gonna go viral but I just want to
be creative so 8020 80% of the content
on your channel is about your niche it's
about the thing that you're doing so
maybe it's about gardening maybe your
whole channel is about gardening okay
and it's all about how to garden it's
all about you know carrots and potatoes
and compost and it's all of those things
but you're also passionate about healthy
living and so maybe you are also a
runner and you say you know I also
really want to talk about how I'm
training for this marathon and I want to
do a vlog about like what my Saturday
looks like in the garden but I'm also
going for a run and all great 8020 80%
of your content is going to be about the
thing and why okay there sure why
because you say so
no because youtube is a computer it's a
machine and it needs to know how to
categorize you it needs to know who do I
serve this content to if YouTube is
confused everyone's confused so you need
to make sure that YouTube understands
the algorithm the machine behind that
the thing understands that I'm a
gardening Channel so serve my stuff up
to anyone who's interested in cartooning
okay but at the same time if you're like
I also impassionate about
I would say keep him within a jacent
topic so that's why I said gardening and
then healthy living because those are
adjacent topics if you're like I'm
passionate about gardening and I'm also
passionate about makeup I would not put
those things on the same Channel I would
choose a different platform
so maybe makeup is you have your own
Instagram just for makeup you can set up
multiple accounts on Instagram and just
talk about makeup and you feel
comfortable about doing that so really
be thinking okay is the topic that I
want to talk about adjacent to what I'm
already currently talking about or is
this like completely different and I'm
sure the next question is well then do I
start a second channel no the second
question is do not start it that answer
is do not start a second Channel
here's the word that we don't want to
hear creators discipline I know I know
it is not the word right now it is not
the word we want to hear it's hard but
you've got to stay disciplined anyone
that is successful right now the people
you look up to the people you admire the
people that you're like how did they get
there they were disciplined they allowed
themselves to stay in one lane for long
enough to break through and that's what
you need to do one lane long enough to
break through so now you see all these
lifestyle like lifestyle channels if you
go back and look at their content
lifestyle channels actually started by
answering specific questions by
answering their viewers questions they
started actually in a niche of some kind
but then they grew to a point where
people were then interested in the green
juice that they drink that morning or
they're interested in the running app
that they use or they're interested in
the hairbrush that they use right like
you start to grow in influence and then
people become more interested but it
doesn't mean pivot off of your channel
it means stay consistent with 80% of
your content about what you want it to
be about and though we do this here at
think media right we make videos all
about the best tips and tools for
growing on YouTube which our biggest
videos are about cameras and are about
lighting and are about music and are
about growing on YouTube but we also
just throw out a video about Monday comm
which is adjacent it's not going to win
the awards of YouTube but
we knew it served up our audience and
we're passionate about productivity and
systems and processes and so we put a
video out about the software that we use
for that absolutely okay this is gonna
be good Heather I know you're gonna drop
a lot of fire on this question I'm ready
for it triple a bumper wants to know
which is greater being yourself or being
different on YouTube Wow um you bu times
to you bu times to meaning Melissa and I
could be making the same type of content
but because of who we are because of our
backgrounds because of our life stages
because of where we've lived and the
experiences we've had it will come
across differently we could be teaching
on the same thing and here's where I
ears are invest analogy Mel if you walk
into Famous Footwear how many different
pairs of shoes do you think there are I
know
thousands it's not like you walk into
famous foot better right Mel and it's
only sneakers right it sneakers it's
high heels it's all these things guys
they're all shoes they're all shoes am I
making the analogy like if you if you're
like oh but someone's already doing it
that's a good thing that means that that
is that is market proof that it's
working that's a good thing if you're
trying to start something and you're
like no one's doing this I've found the
secret to the internet and no one's
talking about this that's actually not a
good thing because there's not been
market proof that that is going to be
working only very very very very few
inventions or businesses or YouTube
channels that are so niche actually work
and so should you be you yes you should
be you times two should you be different
than other people yes you already are
it's already a god-given gift that you
have right now that makes you different
so you and I can be literally talking
about the exact same things we could be
talking about me shame on YouTube yet
your experience and my experience will
bring us to the same conclusion but in
different ways
is what we like to say here at think
media is there's multiple ways up the
mountain there's not just one way to get
to wherever you're trying to go there's
multiple ways up the mountain all right
guys we have a special guest who just
decided to pop in today look at who is
here we've got Sean candle here Wow
we made it and you guys are approaching
it I just got out of the OB appointment
my wife Sonja's healthy pregnant were
revealing the gender tonight rising and
grinding Bevan listen to this whole
session man think marketing community
hit the like button for the fire that
Heather and Mel been dropped and you
guys got to just keep rocking it I'm
just here for the right all right no how
is that was that it was that enough for
them being you times - I think so
there's follow-up questions to that in
the choppa
in the meantime Jordan wants to know he
creates drum covers and content for
local church drummers how should he go
about grabbing ideas first channel okay
one more time he's making content for
local drummers yes for church drummers
and crates draw drum covers oh okay
grabbing ideas for videos really great
okay so um most musicians are also
friends with other musicians so I would
be pulling on the community that you're
already tapped into and I'd be asking
them questions I would be I would be
again number four be for the viewer be
in the community I would start to think
am I connected am I in the community who
do I know right now that could be asking
questions so if you're doing Church
local church drummers there's usually
interns or people who want to be on the
worship team or you know there's people
that are interested in what you're doing
take them to lunch get on a zoom call
with them start asking questions this is
the weird part that people start to feel
kind of like oh but this is you know I
can't ask people you can I have moms
it'll come to me all the time and say
you know Heather how do I start
homeschooling
well that's them reaching out to me but
if I didn't know who I would ask my
community I would go to your Facebook
right now I would go to your Instagram
right now I'd make a post and I would
say hey I am wanting to make videos for
summers what do you need to know so
that's one way okay so actually being in
the community and then the second way is
actually going to youtube search so if
you go to the YouTube search bar you can
actually start typing into the search
and it will auto predict things for you
so if it's drumming for beginners or a
certain cover for beginners
drum solo cover for beginners you can
type that into the youtube search bar
and you can see are people interested it
will start to auto predict for you the
different ways that people are asking
that exact question so that you could
start creating content around that and
then every time a video goes out Shawn
says this all the time 50/50 rule of
content 50% of your time is making the
content and then 50% of your time is
getting that content out to the world
meaning are you sharing it on social are
you helping people find your video are
you sending it to your best friend who's
also a drummer who needs to watch it and
give you critique on it like are you
getting the content out to the world so
that's what I would say it Mel it was
that specific enough to to his problem
yeah I think that's great it really does
come back down to those core principles
that we talk about on the channel all
the time as you're looking for new
content ideas it's about you know
searching it's keyword searching which
we talk we teach a lot here to teach a
lot on think media it's asking a
community for ideas it's truly a kind of
set it's being in the community of what
you're working on so you can be hearing
what people need hearing what people
want and then doing the research to see
what people are searching for as well so
I think that's great
hey and good luck to you because I think
it's really important that you make
content to help people that's what we're
here to do we're here to make content to
help people so if you're doing drum solo
covers or you want to make that type of
content be searching for it be searching
for it in the youtube search bar so you
can see what people are actually asking
for if they're a new drummer is there
like a certain drum set that they should
get you could be reviewing the drum set
are there certain sticks that they need
I don't know anything about drumming so
I would say you know there's beginners
are the best market so if someone wants
to become a drummer on a worship team or
they want to learn drumming what would
they need to know that's where I would
start I would get your journal out and I
would start making know
all the different types of questions you
can answer and make videos for each of
those great so we are angel angel
it's asking it's grow its video live
conference in September still on ooh
will growth video live conference is
still on and I am excited to tell you
some updates and things are going to be
happening in September so make sure you
are subscribed to our email list make
sure that you are receiving our emails
or send us an email we can make sure
that you get subscribed on there because
we have some fabulous things that are
happening in September great ok another
question from Triple A bumper that I
think is really helpful for everybody is
how do you how do tags help bring in
views do they do tags help you a lot and
how do you yes I was just gonna say hey
Shawn this is yeah yeah you know tags
it's a big question and YouTube
themselves have review revealed that
tags themselves listen to this do not
influence you really getting views or
even whether or not you're going to rank
a video in search so what some
surface-level experts have concluded is
they've thrown the baby out with the
bathwater and they've said what tags
don't matter and that's actually
completely false so the question was on
a scale from 1 to 10 how much do they
matter well in isolation and let's put
it this way if you were to shoot a video
and then go pick out the best tags
possible and put a bunch of tags on a
pile of crap then they're gonna have
zero influence in helping that piece of
content that wasn't really created
intelligently or reverse-engineered do
very well but we always say research
before you press record by truly going
and finding influential tags influential
topics search volume what kind of topics
you should be creating and even defining
what your tags should be before you
press record here's a power tip write
this down you want to know what your
title is a concept for your thumbnail
and what your tags are gonna be before
you press record
so like before you even turn the camera
on and shoot your video what is your
title
what is your thumbnail and what are your
tags then when your video comes out and
even using vid IQ or something you see
your tags and like oh wow my video ranks
number four for this keyword phrase aka
tag my video ranks number two for this
it's not the tags that actually
influence the ranking or got you the
views but it is the research and the
intelligence and the architecting of
your content from the tags that is why
you're getting the views so in answer to
your question how important are tags
10/10 because it's just where they are
in the process and what part of the
process they have in relation to
actually influencing your video results
it's all about that topic right Shawn
it's all about choosing the topic first
yeah pound the desk Mel says I've been
pounding a lot man I mean that maybe
it's because my wife's pregnant and
likes that her age is my rage now I'm
like wondering what is a tag yes so a
tag is the area on YouTube where your to
actually um you added in your
description and I'll share my screen
here with you this video that is
actually happening right now is ranking
for how to grow your YouTube channel
it's ranking number four during the
stream of this video so even to say like
is our tags relevant like that's crazy
this is vid IQ showing us and that's
when the powers are live-streaming by
the way when you title your video ahead
of time intelligently which is what
exactly what we just said tag your video
ahead of time strategically it can carry
weight yes there's a whole live stream
strategy to that but then that also has
to do a lot with even your evergreen
video so we put out a new video today
again you have a title that's one area
of the video you have the description
and then you have the tags and that's
this area right here and the reason we
could see this is because of it IQ and
if you want to grab that
free or use the program we use their
paid program it's called boost and all
of that is that think media tools comm
and so right now this video is ranking
for iPhone photography hacks it's
ranking 19 or photo hacks it's ranking
18 in search and that can change
throughout the day but your ultimate
goal is to put out a video like how-to
where you really research before you
press record how to make a video on your
phone which by the way has a lot to do
with empathizing as Heather and mal
we're talking about listen to what your
viewer is actually asking for like most
people had phones they wanted those tips
I was using fancier cameras so Heather
was like let's make a video that's
really gonna help our community help
what people are asking for well as a
result this video all these blue numbers
are all these different tags aka
keyword phrases aka keywords that are
ranking for this video and this video is
getting literally 237 views every 60
minutes about 17,000 views every two
days that's the power of a ranked video
and that's a lot of what we believe you
should be doing here in the think
marketing community is reverse
engineering your content just like this
and then thinking through how you can
get your videos to rank in search and
get you views 24/7 365 whether you're
uploading new content or not and again
if you haven't seen our class on that
think master class com where I go
through step by step how to break some
of those things down but that is that's
the tags area you set that up in the
backend of your YouTube studio and if
you want some more training because I
know it's through a ton at you think
master class dot-com asking how
important is retention and they're
saying there's is about twenty to thirty
five percent twenty to thirty five
percent is really good audience
retention is the metric if there's two
metrics right now that matter most in
2020 and probably into the whole next
decade its average view duration aka
audience retention and it's
click-through rate and the reason we
know this is YouTube studio just reveals
the
directly to us and so if we're inside of
think media's we're on pick marketing
right now you're watching the QA show if
you're getting value hit the like button
if you're grateful for Heather and Mel
hit the like button and we're gonna be
coming at you with this show every other
week so make sure you're subscribed but
when you go in your analytics you want
to make sure you grab a video we can
look at this video that we were just
talking about and we could see the
results of what this video has done so
far and actually the average view
duration on this video now mind you it's
40 minutes long so this is like a
complete tutorial if you haven't watched
this start like how to shoot on your
phone edit a thumbnail on your phone
shoot a thumbnail on your phone edit it
on your phone upload it from your phone
like literally how to make an entire
YouTube video from your phone
but this audience retention metric right
here is average view duration zat 24%
now because the video is so long you can
also go to relative audience retention
and here's a very insightful metric
there's other of course 40 minute videos
on YouTube but this one is above average
this right here if it's above the line
means it's above average for videos of
this length drops it a few points but
the fact that at 32 minutes it's still a
little bit average or a little bit above
and with how much engagement it's
getting in the questions that it answers
this video performs super super well if
we were to look for some of the videos
that have blown up the metric you're
going for is if you can get it over 50
percent right around there's forty nine
point two on this one you're doing
really really good now this is easier
said than done and this is why you want
to be always you know measuring your
content what gets measured gets improved
and be thinking about how can you hold a
viewer retention why do people drop at
certain points what was it about that
moment that was a valley and what was it
about a certain moment that was a peak
and again we're really excited because
we have an announcement coming for you
soon
of a training we're gonna be doing
that's super deep dive a free multi-day
event and so make sure you're subscribed
and on our newsletter and whatnot for
that we're we're gonna be going bye
except you know again it's kind of a lot
of stuff but here's the target as long
as possible on your average view
duration and 50% or above if possible
and you'll really trigger the algorithm
yeah we do have some more questions
about analytics so as Sean mentioned we
will have another great deep dive
training for you guys on that and so be
in our community be on social and be
within our email newsletter so that we
can get you guys all that information
for right now we're gonna this is a
great question for you how they're about
Google Ads so they're asking is it a
good idea to promote their content using
different marketing like paid marketing
yes a really great question because
there is a huge value in using page
traffic but here's the caveat I do not
recommend using paid traffic just to get
views okay
and here's why because if you're gonna
be throwing money at something there
should be money being thrown back at you
at some point okay so here's what this
looks like if you are creating content
for content sake but you don't
necessarily have an ROI a return on
investment metric to actually have that
be of something of value that I do not
recommend it because all it's going to
do is just get you larger exposure but
where do people go from there so if if
you have funds and you're like I want to
beef up my content I want to make sure
that people see what's happening and I'm
also selling something along the pool
along the way then absolutely we do that
here at think media we use YouTube ads
we use Google ads we use Facebook guides
and Instagram ads because we also have
an entire library of educational content
that we sell it's very important that we
know that if we're putting in a thousand
dollars here that we'll also get a
return on our investment over here and
so I recommend that if you're gonna be
using Google Ads that you do it smart
that you're not just throwing money into
into the dumpster and the dumpster fire
of just being able to get more views and
exposure so I know that people do that
and I know that a lot of people will do
that if they're doing like cover songs
or if they want to get discovered and
that is a strategic strategy their ROI
would be signing a record deal so it so
does not make sense I want to make sure
that you understand that that is an
excellent strategy and I highly
recommend
using it but only if you have a way of
knowing what is the return on that
actual ad spent because it's not you're
just throwing money to get exposure okay
so we have time for one more question if
you guys didn't get your question
answered I want to encourage you we are
here for you in so many different
platforms in so many different ways
there are a lot of different places that
you can post your question if you are in
one of our courses in our circle or
video Reiki Academy post your question
within the group not only do is our team
in there daily but other video ink
Academy and inner circle members are
there to help and encourage you if you
are just on our channels and on our
social media post your questions on we
have a lot of different posts that are
going out daily asking you what your
questions are
DMS just get your question to us we love
to serve you guys and we are here for
you and we have a lot of other live
shows that are going to be happening
throughout the next few weeks so as Sean
mentioned make sure that your your
Keaton somehow that you're getting our
emails and our newsletters and our
social posts so you can know what's
going on and we'll see you guys back
here in a couple of weeks but for right
now I just want to end things on one
last question are you are you ready
Heather ready that I'm ready I'm ready
Shawn are you coming on for this one
already we did sure and I also want to
give a quick shout out to the community
as they as something to do next we've
been seeing some incredible engagement
on this post on your tips for what
you've learned in starting YouTube as
well as what you can learn from some of
the people from our community I mean we
have even some big youtubers and some of
the people that have really good
insights so visit over on Instagram at
Shawn Cannell I'll drop that in the live
chat and of course links are always in
the description and drop a comment and
read the comments on this new post over
on Instagram a lot of cool action
happening there that's gonna help you go
further faster on YouTube
mm-hmm okay so our last question is
gonna be from naturally savvy and her
question is how important is the first
24 hours I'm gonna do posts for video ok
such a great question and you know these
days YouTube is really revealed to us
that it's more important than ever
before now it does depend on the ants
the it depends on the age of your
channel like when you're first starting
YouTube doesn't have a huge audience for
you you know you have a lot of
subscribers yet and whatnot and so
that's why it's good to focus on some
longtail keyword phrases aka less
competitive topics get some momentum
going and you really want to post 35 to
55 videos before things really break out
but I think the biggest thing that we
can see is just the fact that YouTube
tells us in YouTube studio on this
latest per video performance and they're
telling us almost like a countdown clock
hey your videos performing as usual look
in the first 7 hours and 57 minutes this
is how good your videos doing and so
spend time in your studio just go in
here click on video analytics of a video
and then read these little quotes that
YouTube's telling you it's like yo your
video did good in the first 7 hours
you've got 3341 huge which is similar to
what you typically get and that is good
and here's how YouTube works as we land
the plane people are subscribed to your
channel but YouTube doesn't even let all
of your subscribers to your video they
only let some of your subscribers see
your video and based on if those
subscribers click on the video and how
long they watch it for and if they
engage with it then what YouTube does
was is it'll let more of your
subscribers see the video and then based
on that engagement they will say ok
people who are not subscribed to think
media or your channel but have the same
viewing patterns and habits and
behaviors like if other people think
media and loves tech we have been
observing that these non subscribers
also are looking for teching cameron
tips we're gonna put this video on their
suggested videos we're gonna put this
video on their homepage and if they
engage with it and you get a good
audience retention and click-through
rate then even more people see it
now it takes a couple days usually for
full audience retention and the full
click-through rate and things like that
to happen but if you can get these
click-through rates up and this a verge
you duration up and you're picking the
right topics again it's called view
velocity and it's called watch time
velocity how quickly do you accumulate
views and the faster you can accumulate
views that's really the essence of a
viral video and viral in your industry
might be 15,000 views for you because
normally you get 500 but all the sudden
this one topic really starts to pick up
speed and then it'll just multiply and
multiply and multiply again to land the
plane this little gray area here in your
YouTube studio is how videos typically
perform that is what that's showing us
but if we were to look at how to make a
video on your phone with Heather here
that we did phone video there we go
compared to how this little tiny gray
line here at the bottom is how a normal
video on think would do and then you see
that this blue line is showing that it
disproportionately is being distributed
and shown to more people in fact
suggested videos is 68% of this
viewership and what we can't go into all
this I know it looks like crazy you know
hieroglyphics kind of but you know
YouTube is recommending this video to
90% of the viewers like they're going
out and saying hey the subscribers a
thick media like this we're gonna show
it to more people summary we got a lot
more training for you to do check out
the master class of course we'll do
future videos on analytics that was a
lot but the summary is try to get as
many views as you can in the first 24
hours if you got an email list let them
know nothing no the new videos out if
you can condition your audience hey
every Tuesday morning is when the new
video comes out go watch it and you can
get as much view momentum as quickly as
possible in those first 3 12 and 24
hours and then really the first week
that is where the magic is
okay thank you so much for jumping on
with us John and for everybody for being
here I'm gonna hand it to Heather but I
did want to just reiterate that we want
to get to all of your questions make
sure that you're here with us in the
next couple weeks when we're back on and
that you're send them send them to us on
Instagram like Sean mentioned YouTube
community all the places yes definitely
and also just remember those four things
we went through I know we just went
through a lot there was a lot that we
just went through but those four things
number one pick your niche you got to
just plant your flag you got to pick
that niche number two we want you to be
answering specific questions number
three be consistent get those uploads
happening and number four before your
viewer thank you so much for watching
today and we'll catch you in the next
video
bye